[Music]
[Music]
their problem so scared PewDiePie starts
early today
so me and Mario decided to go to Little
Tokyo yeah it's a cool place let's go
but first this boxer mag don't you just
love getting a box no I take it all back
right away what the [ __ ] someone send me
a gift
I assume it's from you guys don't
[ __ ] do that thank you
oh my god I take it all back again
I can't believe Mike that he's back I
was so pissed that someone found my
address but you know what this is the
best gift I have ever guy show a clip
from last year basically last year I
have we had this cookbook when I was
vlogging and I kept kissing the guy for
no reason Marc said the book the book is
back someone sent it to us isn't that
crazy
I've been waiting a long time to do this
ah there we go
you
what oh my god it's like a pumpkin ranch
oh my god that's huge that's so cute oh
I feel so down if only something could
save me oh wait what is this yeah I
don't wanna
it's a wellness shot I don't know what's
in it
oh it's good I feel so much better
all right we're at Venice Beach where
all the YouTube videos are made all the
reaction stuff all the fake reactions is
where the real stuff happens
Oh
gross
alright that was that was Franco flowers
Franco
I'll go ahead hey Ken can you do that
dance man oh yeah yeah
last year I was too weak for now wow I'm
writing
- hi-yah you're back lift we're heading
back scare PewDiePie starts now what can
you do what a great day today was the
best day been outside for 10 minutes
breathing this is the vlog guys ten
minutes outside yeah alright bye my
Sarah bye sleepy man it's insane how
busy I am here I know we were just by
the beach or whatever but I was like ten
minutes but still these episodes a
really fun like this season of scare
PewDiePie has been [ __ ] awesome but I
mean let's put it this way if I could
stay home right now and sleep I would
definitely pick that that goes for any
situation actually how many hours three
three hours three hour car ride oh oh
by the end this car ride Brad will have
a strike I have countermeasures today I
wouldn't told you that yeah [ __ ] that's
Nicole countermeasures I brought
what's that
20 can take a brand shirt okay you can
take off my shop together with everybody
opening what's up what's up buddy that's
when he wanted red here's $20 take off
your shirt
I'm gonna put my countermeasure wine
we're gonna get feelings or you want to
spend some money you want to spend some
money water how much you want how much
you thank you all have me gasps what is
this Swedish strength no I'm paying it's
color look at it yeah all right doing
what did you do that just put water on
my shoes for no reason cuz I can't [ __ ]
with your shirt
that's another strike keep yourself
focusing that three hours in
[Music]
no take it
that's tickly that's no fun no one wants
that this is just a beginning
can't you see this damn son what are you
grabbing for it
pickles he's getting the countermeasure
the cameras you talking about he has a
countermeasure break this shirt apart
there's holes in you want them come on
do it
I'll hold your money for you you got you
got destroy my he can do it [ __ ]
I know you're poor but each puppet where
do you get this we can ask what do you
have been what is it Rick get the
countermeasure
[Music]
ah do it what what did the [ __ ] are you
doing
I get it
just keep going let's help him out we
finally yeah come on in here boy
but you edit it out strike you edit it
out a strike that's three strikes ha ha
ha four strikes so smart of course you
get one strike because you got strike
for this footage of the egg is there was
a heinous the egg back on you can't
directly [ __ ] with my shirt I just
hacked you so then Michael like ran
after because I didn't thought that to
strike that you can touch me when I can
touch you that you can tell if you get
egg on the shirt just matter you can
have whatever yard you should be what
you're breaking this strike sir tearing
us apart
yeah is that we said get everything this
strike is really friendships
this is what we Swedish people do thug
in the in the high schools it's hard
oh the Antron blonde hair study every
meal Vilma oh yeah yeah a special grace
a Moscato my curare Henry to be so
destitute okay how does it happen to you
what have you become
look at you look away you've become
I'm empowered I've never been so proud
to wear these colors
[Music]
cinamon today's ching-fen city see you
here you want to arm-wrestle yeah I want
to arm-wrestle well the winner gets the
other person's YouTube channel ready in
3 2 1 come off you that you can do it
come on
come on Felix come on can I come on do
it
you can you again
yes Pete if I win Oh [ __ ] idiot ah ah
squeeze my finger oh man I break your
fingers I broke my right say I wrote my
finger thumbnail yeah um that day how do
I make you look even broker ah I broke
my fingers it's not a good time now
would you click a knife i come [ __ ]
with it clickbait check out what next
flick away we're gonna do him tomorrow
[Music]
you smell like [ __ ] do it sorry to tell
you that I wonder why give me a hug no
give me a hug
you can't come on yeah destroy I'll take
a strike look what as you can see I'm
covered and [ __ ] and if you want to find
out why you got to watch scare PewDiePie
hope you enjoy this brother bow as
always thanks for living alike I'll see
you bro in the next episode hidden in
here no no listen well that's why I was
in a different spot what do we got
that's actually gonna cover the game
glich get election a dick
[Music]